THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE
WANTED TO ENABLE PEOPLE TO DO
BOTH.
>> I WANT TO BRING THE AMOUNT BY
PHONE REPUBLICANS AND THE SCOTT
OF FLORIDA COME OVER AGAIN YOU
HAVE CHOSEN TO LET THE VOTING
CONTINUING YOUR STATE.
NOT YOU PERSONALLY BUT EVERYONE
TOGETHER.
WHY WAS THAT DECISION MADE?
>> IT WAS A DECISION -- IN
FLORIDA AT WHAT YOU HAVE IS YOU
HAVE EARLY VOTING, YOU HAVE MAIL
IN BALLOTS, AND THEN YOU HAVE
VOTING ON ELECTION DAY.
OUR SUPERVISOR ELECTION ARE
LOCATED BY COUNTY.
EVERY PERSON IN THAT COUNTY CAN
REACH OUT TO THEIR SUPERVISOR
AND ASK THEM HOW THEY ARE MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
FAITHFUL.
THE POOL WATERS NEED TO BE SAFE.
WE NEED TO HAVE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THE PEOPLE COMING
INTO VOTE.
MY EXPECTATION IS EVERY
SUPERVISOR IN FLORIDA HAS DONE
THAT.
>> YOU ARE A FORMER FLORIDA
GOVERNOR, YOU WEARS SEVERAL
HATS.
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE CAN
LEADLIEN ON.
HAS GOVERNOR TO SANTOS REACHED
OUT AND SAID DO WE NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THIS?
WE AS AMERICANS ARE BEING TOLD
TO STAY ON WAS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
DOES THIS FLY IN THE FACE OF
THAT?
>> I HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
GOVERNOR DESANTO’S.
IF THE DECISION THEY MADE AND MY
EXPECTATION IS -- FIRST OFF, THE
POLL WORKERS HAVE TO BE SAFE.
A LOT OF THESE WORKERS ARE THE
AGE GROUP WHERE THEY ARE
ADDRESSED.
MY EXPECTATION IS THAT THE
SUPERVISORS I’VE DONE THEIR JOB.
>> THAT’S AN INTERESTING POINT
ABOUT THEM FITTING RIGHT INTO
THE LIEN OF THOSE WE ARE TRYING
TO PROTECT.
THE PRESIDENT WEIGHED IN ON
GOVERNOR PULLING OFF OHIO’S
PRIMARY TODAY.
LET’S WATCH AND I WILL GET YOUR
REACTION.
>> THEY ARE GOING BY THE RULE OF
TEN AS OPPOSED TO 50, THAT’S
PRETTY TOUGH.
I WOULD SAY PROBABLY YOU COULD
VIOLATE THAT IF YOU WANTED TO
FOR AN ELECTION.
I THINK AN ELECTION IS A VERY
SPECIAL THING.
HE CHOSE A DIFFERENT DATE, SOME
DAY IN JUNE.
THAT WOULD BE A DECISION MADE BY
HIM.
>> SENATOR?
>> I DON’T KNOW HOW THERE IS IS
SET UP BUT MY EXPECTATION IS --
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE NOBODY HAS
FEVERS, DID THEY DO THE PROPER
SOCIAL DISTANCING?
HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE
SAFE?
AND THEN HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE
PEOPLE COME IN SAFE.
>> YOU BRING UP SOME REALLY
SALIENT POINTS.
OHIO IS NOT THE ONLY STATE TO
CANCEL.
WE SAW GEORGETTE -- SOME OF THE
OTHERS THAT HAVE CANCELED ARE A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER OUT THAN WE
ARE NOW BUT LOOKING AHEAD, HOW
DO YOU THINK BIG PICTURE -- HOW
DO YOU SEE THIS PLAYING OUT?
THIS IS DIFFICULT.
WE COULD BE IN THIS MODE OF
TRYING TO KEEP THE NUMBERS DOWN
AND FLATTEN OUT THAT CONTAGION
CURVE.
>> WHETHER WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE ECONOMY OR THE ELECTIONS
EVERYTHING COMES DOWN TO HOW WE
ARE DEALING WITH CORONAVIRUS.
I THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE MORE
EXTREME MEASURES THEN WHERE WE
ARE.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET UP TESTING
SITES NOW.
BY FAR EVERY TOWN IN THIS
COUNTRY OUGHT TO HAVE A MOBILE
TESTING SITE SO PEOPLE CAN GET A
TEST AND SO THAT WE DON’T HAVE A
CHANCE OF INFECTING OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, WHICH ARE
HOPEFULLY GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
US IF WE GET SICK.
WE’VE GOT TO CLOSE OUR BORDERS.
THESE GOVERNORS HAVE GOT TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY AND SAY I’M GOING
TO STOP -- I’M GOING TO MAKE
SURE WE PREVENT LARGE SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS.
I’M WORRIED ABOUT OUR SUPPLY
LINE.
I’M WORRIED ABOUT OUR DRUGS.
I’M WORRIED ABOUT A PRICE
GOUGING.
AT EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
WOULD GOT TO STEP UP AND SAY
THIS IS BIGGER THAN WHAT WE
THOUGHT BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE DIDN’T THINK THIS WAS AS
BIG.
I’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
TWO MONTHS.
YOU CAN WATCH WHAT WAS HAPPENING
IN CHINA.
WE’VE GOT IT BE TAKING MORE
SERIOUSLY.
YOU AND ME, IN THE END I’VE GOT
TO TAKE CARE OF MY FAMILY,
YOU’VE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF
YOURS, OUR CHURCHES, EVERYBODY
HAS TO GET INVOLVED IN THIS.
>> WE ARE PART OF A BIGGER
FAMILY.
THEY HOLD THEM YOU WERE TALKING
WE WERE SHOWING SOME OF THAT
POLLING VIDEO COMING OUT THE
VIDEO FROM A LITTLE BIT EARLIER.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING, THAT SPACING WITH
THE BOOTHS RIGHT NEXT TO EACH
OTHER.
THAT IS A BIG JOB AT THE POLLS
RIGHT TODAY.
FORMER GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA,